[Music]
the fate of the white helmets will be
the same as that of any terrorist they
have two paths either lay down their
arms and take advantage of the amnesty
or be wiped out like other terrorists
[Music]
when this
Hey
[Music]
and the Oscar goes to the white omelet
[Applause]
[Music]
we were in the basement my mother told
me that we had run out of food and
wouldn't have anything to eat until
tomorrow I heard noise outside
somebody was shouting that we had to go
to the hospital so we went there when I
came in some people brought me started
pouring water on my head and now that's
me in the video that's me yes the Syrian
first responders who risk their lives to
save others in war-torn 11 basic
unrelenting tality euros heavy money
they would bring cameras and explosives
something to destroy for example this
building here they'd find people in the
streets and promised the money or food
to say whatever they need
whenever food aid was brought in tea
Stiletto the white helmets and ruffles
would take it all for themselves they
give us nothing not even forehead
[Music]
they have all chosen to risk their lives
to save others with white helmets that
cool the white helmets or the Civil
Defence helping people when they were
injured when they came to help the
injured they stole from it if people
were wearing jewelry they cut it off
all of them are thieves some of them are
honest but many are just thieves they
see gold and they take it this man
accused the organization of
intentionally killing his little girl I
took her to the Civil Defence Hospital
and they gave her an injection filled
with air to kill her we've been able to
get these brave people and their
families out of Syria after the
extraordinary work they've done saving
lives the white helmets those people
they helped the rebels only that in save
civilians learn the logs out rebels